il y a une nouvelle arnaque qui c
particulièrement les grands-parents je
vous dis
euh pour vous ça compte pas beaucoup
pour ceux qui pratiquement tous ceux qui
sont autour de la table le but autant de
se faire passer pour les petits enfants
demandant de l'argent ou un virement
pour Noël tuas vu ça ou pas oui je l'ai
eu quoi tu l'as eu je l'ai eu ma fille
m'a envoyé effectivement ma fille la
fille qui essayie de t'arnaquer non par
non j'ai cru le coucou papa là c'est ça
dont vous
parlezzar toi en fait il t'arrive que
des
meres ils ont tous numéro SMS envoyé sur
votre téléphone par des escrocs avec un
but bien précis vous soutirez autant
d'argent que possible en se faisant
passer pour votre enfant bonjour Maman
j'ai laissé tomber mon téléphone dans
les toilettes pour moi j'en ai conclu
que c'était soit mon fils soit ma fille
donc du coup j'ai j'ai répondu je suis
allée sur le lien l'escrot assure alors
avoir besoin d'argent pour acheter un
nouveau téléphone ou régler une facture
c'est là que le doute s'installe et
qu'elle cesse de R
répondre alors oui en fait c'est hyper
bien fait parce que là à froid on se dit
mais il faut être stupide mais quand ça
vous arrive coucou papa j'ai perdu mon
téléphone j'ai une urgence appelle-moi
sur ce nouveau numéro s'il te plaît
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous appelez
donc ça ne répond pas après vous appelez
la maman vous appelez l'établissement
vous appelez partout vous êtes en
panique et il y a des gens qui eux sont
tombés sur quelqu'un ils ont pas eu un
répondeur on vous dit votre fille est en
galère tout de suite ils ont une chance
sur deux he c'est fils ou fille là
c'était votre fille est en galère et
donc à ce moment-là sa oui c'est fille
souffille en fait oui non mais je veux
dire eux ils répondent c'est-à-dire que
si l'Arque mais non mais si Cyril vous
rappelez et on vous dit votre fille est
en galère elle a besoin d'argent
qu'est-ce que vous faites j'en ai à
moi ah oui
mais vous savez qu'on l' fait à moi
est-ce que vous l'avez eu cette arnaque
genre sur des mails si si je vous le dis
genre un mec un pote à vous je sais pas
comment ils font est loin ils disent
voilà truc je vous jure que ça m'a
arrivé deux trois fois et moi je savais
pas que cé arnaque et un mec qui me dit
cyil j'ai besoin de 3000 € ou c'est le
seul fois que je rép frère tu avais qu'à
débrouiller tout seul j'en ai à
non mais sans déconner c'est vrai je
vous jure que c'est vrai et après j'ai
appris que c'était une arnaque et en
fait vousz vous l'z pas vu ce truc
là fait il rentre dans votre répertoire
donc il trouve ou dans vos mails en fait
et il trouve des correspondants et ils
se disent voilà exactement m' demandé de
l'osille à moi ouis j'ai d frèreen fout
moi voilà et même ma fille donc ta fille
elle te dit je suis en galère mais là
moi ça n'a pas marché mais ça va jusque
là le gars dit votre fille est en galère
elle a besoin d'urgence d'un dépannage
si vous ne la sauvez pas il va lui
arriver les pires trucs donc qu'est-ce
mais oui mais qu'est-ce que vous faites
dans ces cas-là vous dites comment je
peux faire vous êtes où j'arrive et
cetera ça il fait bien que ma mère
regarde ça c'est intr c'est inextrémiste
que je me suis pas fait arnaquéanchement
ça fait peur c'est extrêmement plausible
parce effectivement vos votre enfant
peut avoir perdu son téléphone et
prendre le téléphone d'un ami dont vous
n'avez pas le numéro il dit maman je
suis sur le téléphone de Josiane qui est
ma copine
et très moderne cétait la sa pas qui est
cette j imagine je prends le téléphone
de Kelly voilà et je t'appelle du
téléphone de Kelly rappelle-moi ce
numéro parce que j'ai perdu mon mon
téléphone et quand on rappelle à partir
de là c'est fini il y a un truc
imparable en ce moment dans SMS puisque
c'est bientôt Noël beaucoup de gens
commandent sur Internet et donc on
reçoit un sms votre livraison va arriver
je l' aujourd'hui celui-là
aussiour
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui avec un numéro
jusqu'au num et comme on attend vraiment
un colis pour de bon bah du coup on
clique parce qu'on se dit bah je vais
prendre rendez-vous pour la livraison
voir mais là a des PES de l'année comme
aujourd'hui c'est il a une autre arnaque
c'est un faux colis oui vousz vu ça au
pasez je connais moi j'ai aucune arnaque
moi chance mais bon c'est vrai que je
vais pas chercher souvent des colis
encore qui reçoit encore des colis ah
bah
oui ah ouais quand même oui ça fait des
années que j'ai rien reçu Mo vous avez
rien commandé en même temps
Annique je peux vous dire un truc là
tous ou on est beau non je vous dis
juste un truc et je dis devant les
téléspectateurs à 20h on direct tu nous
aimes tu av tendance à mal me regarder
ah bon
paranoion là il y a eu un regard qui a
déclenché cette analyse c'est le regard
de qui vous avez tendance à mal me
regarder d'entre vous RM ceux qui me
regardent mal Raymon Gilles Montiel ah
oui Hugo Kelly beaucoup c'est quoi qu'on
regarde ahon c'est regarde mal on regard
genre on a envie de s'embrouiller avec
toi je pense vraiment tu ressens comme
ça comme ça je sens de l'animosité de
l'ité non c'est du désir c'est du désir
mais je vous le dis ah ouais c'est pas
notre style ça dis débat de tu faire
débat de l'uniforme non non regardez
l'arnaque des colis dans la colis ah oua
des arnaques toujours plus réalistes et
généralement plus nombreuses à
l'approche des fêtes comme par exemple
les fausses livraisons de colis alors
que beaucoup optent pour les commandes
de cadeau en ligne le SMS que vous allez
recevoir va vous inciter à cliquer pour
par exemple euh compléter un
affranchissement de colis et vous allez
rentrer des données personnelles vous
allez rentrer votre numéro de carte
bancaire une fois les informations
collectées elles peuvent être
réutilisées pour vous soutirer encore
plus d'argent alors un conseil pour ne
pas gâcher la fête le plus prudent reste
de ne jamais cliquer sur le lien qui
vous est envoyé so Jama col alors euh
oui j'en ai reçu un moi32 hier avec le
vrai logo et tout c Moon le vrai logo et
ça franchement j'ai failli me faire
avec un lien et tout voil et donc on va
vérifier après c'est trop tard il est
beau
celu je vais revenir sur les produits
aux étiquettes mensongères un saumon
plus cher avec 10 g de moins vous l'avez
vu celui
ouais du sa
[Rires]
ryth le pain d'épic au miel sans miel
honte d'épic au miel sans miel ça existe
prend des P ou au miel ont l'odeur du
miel qu' a de la
ménagère on devient ménagère avec le
temps Z la
Bou P j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle augmentation j'allais dire ça
je te jure c'est vrai je vous dis j'ai
une très bonne nouvelle je peux pas
vous un rêve se
réalise non pas du tout c'est pas un
achat incl dans c'est une proposition
énorme qui vient d'arriver pour moi
partager ave professionn prof terrible
pour les gens là qui regardent g une
paire une paire non pas du tout c'est
pas dans le pad c'est dans un nouveau
sport une
marque de combat ah ouais viens d'avoir
une proposition exceptionnelle comme un
fou je vais vous en parler plus tard
quand ce sera fait mais je suis très
très content je suis c'est c'est un de
mes rêves qui se réalise VO donc je
voulais vous
dire avec des Saint-Jacques
d'Argentine la transition elle est
folle n'importe quoi je vais réaliser un
rêve une terrine
Bron qui est là là pour en
fait c'est le meilleur pilote
d'émission citron prix du citron ah
aussi mais c'est quoi ces
infos non mais c'est ce qu'on
disaitement ce qu'on disit c'est c'est
vousz déjà dit c'est de l'eau c'est de
l'eau c'est de l'eau au prix du citron
c'est pas une le principe c'est le même
c'est que voilà ce qui est annoncé n'est
pas ce qui est dans la dans la boîte
donc encore une fois le Conil c'est V
dire la composition parce que on peut
pas ne pas mettre dans la composition au
moins un peu du produit si on vous dit
voilà il y a du citron ou il y a du
chocolat s en a pas du tout là on est
dans le dél euh la pratique trompeuse
mais en fait la loi elle vous dit qu'il
faut que l'affirmation soit fausse ou ou
partiellement fausse pour dire que c'est
un délit mais donc ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'en fait ils vous mettent un peu de
chocolat mais il y a pas à l'image on a
l'impression que c'est un gâteau
entièrement chocolaté un tout petit peu
il faut qu' un tout petit peu sielle a
pas du tout là on est dans le dél et a
feros rocher qui vont un sachet de
chocolat composé à 52 % vide ouais c'est
l'emballage l'emballage qui est qui est
important mais en fait quand on regarde
la moitié c'est du vide et eux vous
disent oui mais c'est pour la
conservation donc ils ont en fait
réponse à tout à chaque fois bah oui
mais c'est c'est faites vos courses vous
regardez les codes bar des produits que
vous achetez quand il fait
quoi avec le CAD quand vous faites vos
courses quand est-ce que vous avez fait
vos courses pour la dernière fois Franch
donc par exemple le COD bar par exemple
il y
aen Montaigne des courses de bouffe
ou genre des pâes des SA vous trompez
parce que je je vous j'ai adoré aller
faire les coursesouz les épaules en
général c'est que vous
mentez je vous dis la vérité j'adorais
aller faire les cours vous adoriez mais
il y a pas le temps en quelle année a
quelques quelques quelques semaines donc
je vais vous donner un truc puisque vous
aimez la gastronomie italienne quand
vous allez dans un supermarché et vous
regardez les codes bar et par exemple il
y a marqué gsto Italia tout ça vous
regardez le Code Bar et souvent les
codes bar en fait sont pas du tout
italiens en fait si c'est ça commence
par 80 là ça vient d'Italie et c'est
très bien sinon ça vient de n'importe où
sauf de l'Italie c'est une B un bon truc
par que les produit n'ont rien à voir
les mecs j'ai rien à la maison je vous
dis la vérité je fais pas les courses
rien à la maison vous ouvrez mon mon
frigo il y a du cocazeron mais vous DZ
quoi du coup le soir quand vous rentrez
je je d pas je me fais me fais unouo sur
le
pouce comme ça quoi tu vois tranquille
quoi ou
[Applaudissements]
merciors VI